utility now has an inspect animation in
Counterstrike 2 we're going to see which
are the best ones okay first things
first smoke I feel like the smoke one's
really boring and even when you get the
rare smoke one it's like not very cool
let's do H I actually don't mind the
basic inspect animation it's not bad
actually the rare one's nice this one's
cool you're making your way over a
banana get a nice little juggly jug all
right Flash the basic inspect animation
is actually not bad but yo the rare one
sh oh it's like inspecting your knife
decoy grenade low key kind of sick
oo oh that's clean I like this one too
bad I'm never going to buy this grenade
most underrated 100% is the bomb dude
I'm telling you you can hold it down and
you can just run around spin in the
beblade bro okay so the Molly regular
inspect animation I just holding it's
really nice you know you're checking out
what year it is it's a 2001 you know
it's a vintage I like the rare one but
the real reason everybody loves this
obviously is just because of
this s+